hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play slender
the arrival
okay I've calmed down quite a bit since
my last playthrough this and someone
said that I needed to right mouse button
so that I could blind the little kid no
one seems to be sure if that's masky or
not so I'm just calling a little
douchebag and I'm and I read that
comment I was like [ __ ] over back I know
I'm okay I'm just gonna calm down I had
no idea that that was a thing that I
needed to do but you know whatever let's
just let's get this done now now that I
know how to counteract him I guess it
should be a little easier maybe I just
got to worry about Slendy now a
Slenderman seems to be okay so much said
that the little kid might actually be
one of Slenderman z' proxies which um if
you watch there's a whole lot of stuff
on YouTube about of the idea of
Slenderman in his proxies you can you
can check it all for yourself
watch the Marble Hornets stuff watch all
the other stuff watch the movie there's
a movie about it him there the thing
whatever he is whatever he/she may be
cheap yeah easier a little early that a
little scampering bastard hey what's up
buddy I got a flashlight with your name
on it you dick look at this I got one
down here you're so boned I bet there's
one up there ah no you're not but to do
that you're going to be blinded you [ __ ]
don't be blinded you dick this is not
working someone lied to me and what was
that [ __ ] did you see that did you
see what that was all about
because I saw it I was there I saw how
much bull that was
oh you gotta be joking I don't even know
if the flashlight technique worked
what kind of douchebag move is double
jumping me like that I bet the makers of
this game if they ever see my video or
like he's so stupid oh god we made these
mechanic did to fit with markiplier oh
we're so happy that we managed to do
that I swear I'm gonna stab someone in
the crotch someone's getting crotch
stabbed and they're getting crotch
stabbed real hard okay whatever I'll try
the focus beam if he actually stays away
from me the douche I'm just gonna take
this nice and calm I hear you I hear you
I hear you
where are you
I hear you there's not one down there
very a bit
I hear you where the f are you where are
you all right you little prick ah get
blinded you [ __ ] be blinded yak right
suck suck ten thousand [ __ ] right there
in your eyeballs yeah I'm the greatest
yes I'm all powerful light light
flashlight man that's what I am that's
my superhero name from now on everyone
referred to me as light flashing man
flashlight man Adele hahahahaha
I know oh it sucks for you Oh what that
don't do new hey hey that's right you
stay back
haha I've got him now and now I've got
super speed oh look at me go oh what's
it's how fast am i oh
so fast markiplier you're so fast I know
I know because I am that fast let's get
this before you makes his way down here
check the upstairs ones up oh wait he's
probably coming around that corner
pretty soon
get up there oh don't no no no no yes
son of a [ __ ] get off of me
you don't do the double jumping
douchebag maneuver son of a [ __ ] I hate
you so much
get off of me don't you know who I am
I'm flashlight man oh there's another
one down there I'll catch it on the way
down
ha thought I heard you okay that's what
that'll make 5 of 6 which is pretty good
and I should be able to swing around
hopefully it'll be around this back way
if not it'll be in the back tunnel and
I'll be able to get out of here I don't
hear him yet so he should be a ways away
yes I'm gonna make it this time and if I
don't I will be totally calm and
collected about it I won't freak out at
all you know where's Slenderman in all
of this he hasn't shown his face in a
while I'm actually kind of worried now
cuz I said I said his name he will be
summoned it's gotta be here somewhere
no you don't little [ __ ] bag that's
right back off I got them strobe
technique is not working hey stop yeah
yeah yeah yeah that that will happen
what boo ski running away oh it's a dead
boy don't boo ski come on get him get up
get up got right
oh what's that did that hurt your eyes
too bad
Oh super speed now okay it's not this
way but I'll loop around try to catch
him on the flip side yeah doing good so
far
oh no is he gonna take the shortcut is
he coming back I knew ho ho ah super
speed
god I'm so great I'm just amazing in
every way
I'm gonna go circle around the other way
it's got to be that way this'll a whole
thinks he's got me or no oh what's that
oh did I hurt your eyes good help
Slenderman comes up behind you and
stabbed you in the nerds all right I've
got to be getting close to it and I put
some considerable distance between me
and him so let me just walk for a bit
hopefully no panicking Slenderman
moments will happen cuz I am calm and
all is that a red glow I see no that's
just red brick
I know he was coming soon just a matter
of time Oh what's this ha yeah but ah
good I got him so you were no other way
Simon's gone I had SuperSpeed for like
two seconds get oh the strobe technique
the strobe technique you can't handle
the strobe technique oh yeah
super speed I just got to get in this
before he gets by because he grabbed me
last time okay booter ski i can't move
so that's son of a [ __ ] oh I'm up and
out of here I'm up and out of here yes
oh yeah suit to pro can I possibly be to
pro it is possible I'm so great is he up
here that he's up here to our right that
was such a dick
uh-huh
ah you know there comes a time in a
man's life when he reaches a breaking
point at which this curse that I have
this burden that I bear where I have
this unescapable ability to break games
and get the last and sucking on the last
teeth of the game developer and I'm just
I can't take it anymore
I want this curse to be lifted I am the
game breaker but that I hate my life
I hate my life
you I will no I'm not in the mood it's
not down there where are you come on
where are you where are you you behind
me you're going up the back stairs
aren't you
is that a glow I saw I don't think so
no right whatever oh man I'm so pissed
I'm a dog don't be confused by the smile
I am so angry right now I'm where are
you you're coming around that corner
where are you where are you Oh Dubinsky
oh-oh-oh-oh to pro do pro it seems I
could get a super sprint every time I
spot one of them so this allows me
plenty of sprinting time oh what's that
what's that little bunny oh is that
you're a douche ah don't be so hard on
yourself I mean it's true but you don't
need to call yourself that I'll call you
that all you want
got another one here come on pop in pop
out zap them zap them oh oh did that
hurt your eyeballs Oh candy down there
and looks like that's a no grub boom
door Bruschi aha there's one hey buddy
oh you're up there and I'm down here
what are you gonna do about that on
nothing raise how'd you get your uncle
Slendy to stop me oh wait he can't cuz
he's an a-hole who's really bad at
drawing I'm just walking calmly I don't
need to sprint we you're talking about
I'm totes mix crouched relaxed breath I
am calm and collected anything no oh
it's uncle Slendy sorry I called your
art bad but ah sorry I suck so much
excuse me need to run this way don't
feel it last one will be over here I'm
now you off fudge it's not ah you're way
too close for comfort man you're way too
close you should not be this close I
can't sprint I need a sprint boost give
me a sprint boost I just had a sprint
boost stop messing with my camera it's
very expensive oh no don't tell me don't
meet me around this corner bro what up
line up
there we go Oh what does it that was it
oh fudge I hear the pitter-patter of
little shoes where are you where are you
your uncle Slendy can't protect you now
boots that's right
sprint superboost where is the last one
please dear God game do not bug out on
me I can't take it anymore
I can't take it I'm losing my mind
people want to see me get past this part
I can't take it anymore ah stop it's
Lindy
stop it
that's where the last one is I know
you're guarding it you son of a [ __ ]
you're such an a-hole where is he gonna
pop up he's right by me yes be blinded
god damn god damn I swear
oh man okay what whoa was that a glow
what's that a glow is that a glow in
there is that a glow
that's a glow that's a win all yeah come
on where is he
where is he I'll [ __ ] it all going
around give me more room away from them
anyway yeah I knew it if I'd gone down
there I would have been right up in him
right up in his business I knew it good
instincts markiplier my thank you Mark
wow you sure are handsome and smart
I know right I am so many both of those
things all right where's the
pitter-patter of little feet
I want to blind them get to the toner
get to the toner all right please dear
God game do not bug out on me I would
rather not have bugs oh no you don't
know no oh no aah all right now game
seriously seriously game I don't know
what you're gonna do but let me get over
this ledge just let me cross okay run oh
I almost fell through I almost fell
through again holy balls yes I was too
stepped from the loading screen are you
kidding me are you kidding me god damn
my curse I can't take the curse anymore
all right so I'm hoping I'm hoping that
this is another chapter select I'm
hoping cuz I'm done for now
I can't take much more of this game I
mean that little [ __ ] Oh deserves to be
punched in the crotch so many times
we're gonna have a dick punching party
on whoever the hell that is
yeah all right so whatever so thank you
all so much for watching I still
recommend this game no matter how many
troubles I've had
it's still a great game so thank you all
so much for watching click the
annotation for more reviews is I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
you lock your door
ah
buzz
Oh